when it comes to retail shopping
statistically there is no day more
harmful to your physical well-being than
Black Friday it's a day that can even be
fatal in 2008 customers broke down the
doors at a Walmart in Valley Stream New
York and an employee was killed in the
ensuing stampede since then the
Occupational Safety and Health
Administration or OSHA has issued safety
guidelines for stores wanting to avoid a
similar in sand why do people go so
crazy on Black Friday
it's the deals of course the deals the
opportunity to get a 32 inch plasma TV
for a hundred and seventy nine dollars
the chance to finish all your Christmas
shopping in one go the super big huge
promises of such car accident savings
have traditionally made Black Friday the
most profitable shopping day of the year
indeed a number of businesses that
operate at a financial loss between
January and November once mark read in
ledger books report sales during the
holiday season that make the entire year
profitable profits by the way are
written in black ink
hence Black Friday but but but but the
only problem is both the name and the
savings of Black Friday aren't exactly
what they seem
let me explain the first instances of
the term Black Friday actually have
nothing to do with accounting jargon but
with a newsletter from the Philadelphia
Police Department in the 1960s lamenting
the huge crowds traffic jams in general
chaos on the day after Thanksgiving it
was not a term of endearment for Philly
cops not by a long shot despite efforts
to change the name to big Friday the
term stuck so it was left to marketing
executives to put a positive spin on the
whole thing and that's how you get the
black ink here and indeed like the name
the promise savings of Black Friday are
largely an illusion as well an allusion
carefully designed for you
the customer to act as irrationally and
stupidly as possible big-box stores like
Walmart and Target and Best Buy don't
put everything out for sale on Black
Friday instead they put out select items
as loss leaders products sold at or
close to a loss for the company
to get you in the door and amongst
everything else they're still selling at
high margin you've got the TV but now
you need the normally priced wall mount
the normally priced HDMI cables and the
normally priced Roku actually when you
look again you see that the Roku though
normally price comes with a $40 rebate
which you can get back in two months not
bad except for about 60% of rebates
never get fulfilled because people just
forget or they fail to comply with all
the print requirements they didn't read
when rushing around Best Buy in friends
indeed retailers know exactly what it's
like to be a hectic shopping environment
and they exploit it to the extreme they
know that rebates feel good but people
forget they know that warranties may
seem like peace of mind in the checkout
lane but actually fuel a fifteen billion
dollar industry of pure profit oh that
pure profit feel so good they know that
we shop by means of rationalization and
justification that by putting a super
expensive item next to a normally price
one will increase the sales of the
latter because we don't see price we see
price different they know everything
that this article by economic
researchers proved with the help of MRI
scans that we are not rational actors
when we shop but that the image of the
deal lights up our brain with pleasure
like a Christmas tree and that we choose
between that pleasure and the pain of
spending when deciding on a purchase
retailers do everything they can to
remove the immediate pain of spending
hence rebates in-store credit cards and
solvent plants and alike but it's these
things often riddled with hidden fees
and hula-hoops that end up killing and
eclipsing the savings you thought you
were getting in the first place as there
are Thomson writes in the Atlantic the
first and last rule of prices is that
nobody knows what anything is really
worth shoppers are guided by shallow
clues this is cheaper than that and
latent emotions it just feels like a
good deal rather than knowledge and
deliberate thinking but this isn't just
the case for Black Friday and
increasingly anachronistic term in a
world of cyber Mondays and gray
Thursdays where Santa is an employee of
Ford and Chevy and mercedes-benz it's
true the whole year round perhaps in
this case the black ink theory is worth
keeping in mind
it's the retailers that go into the
black on Black Friday
the customers think of it that way and
it's easier to see that despite every
single ad saying otherwise the day was
never really about you it's about them
hey everybody thanks for watching and
Happy Thanksgiving there is so much more
to say about Black Friday particularly
how it relates to economic inequality in
our country I didn't get into that but
if you want to read more about it you
can find that in the description this
Thanksgiving I am grateful to you all of
you thank you so much for watching and
engaging all the comments on last week's
video about sexism or amazing incredibly
thought out and I'm so glad I got to
have the conversation with you in
comments that's where it's always
happening so I'm in comments and you can
comment and I will respond to you make
sure to follow me on Twitter if you
haven't already a lot of you guys did
last week thank you for that and I will
see you next time
that's my commercial voice you can find
my resume for voice over work in the
description I have no resume